in 1932 the united states public health
service began a study of the effects of
untreated syphilis on black men in macon
county alabama
participants informed consent was not
collected
the study initially involved 600 black
men
399 with syphilis 201 who did not have
the disease
researchers told the men they were being
treated for bad blood a local term used
to describe several ailments including
syphilis anemia and fatigue in exchange
for taking part in the study the men
received free medical exams free meals
and burial insurance
four decades later on july 25 1972
associated press reporter gene heller
broke news about the study
prompting the u.s department of health
education and welfare to appoint an ad
hoc panel to investigate
in october 1972
the panel advised stopping the study and
a month later the study was ended
the panel concluded in their final
report that the previous research on
african americans with syphilis was
ethically unjustified
at the study's conclusion only 74 of the
original 600 men were still alive
40 of their wives had been infected and
19 of their children were born with
congenital syphilis
the advisory panel's investigation led
to compensation for the victims of the
research and new protocols for the
ethical treatment of human subjects of
research voluntary informed consent for
research subjects became the new
standard and an explicit requirement for
government-funded research
in 1997 president clinton issued a
formal presidential apology for the
tuskegee syphilis study
during its investigation the panel
collected a broad variety of historical
documents and other papers
in 1973
a copy of the panel's working papers was
deposited in the national library of
medicine nlm located on the campus of
the national institutes of health in
bethesda maryland
through this research and related public
education made possible by the unique
collection held by the nlm as well as
the national archives we acknowledge the
participants in the tuskegee study and
the injustices they and their families
suffered
we also acknowledged the work of the
tuskegee syphilis study ad hoc advisory
panel to address the unethical actions
of the study which ushered in new
protections for the rights of patients
and which continue to evolve with new
advances in science and medicine
the mlm collects and preserves
collections such as that of the tuskegee
study ad hoc advisory panel
to improve transparency in research and
to ensure that lessons of the past
inform the present and future of
biomedical research health care public
health and healthy behavior